uh joe burrow the unquestioned starting
quarterback of the cincinnati bengals
he
could use some help either at skilled
positions or at offensive line or really
both they've got the fifth overall pick
in the draft he spoke earlier this week
uh to chris collinsworth about
the fact that he's not
making any effort to try to persuade the
bengals to do any specific thing with
that fifth overall pick here's joe
burrow
i haven't offered up any strong opinion
well let me give you a couple then
[Laughter]
you know i'm great friends with jamar
we've been talking
for a year since we stopped playing
together we talked you know last week so
i'm great friends with jamar i know the
kind of player that he is but i think
we're in a great spot i think
a lot of the picks in front of us will
be quarterbacks not sure how many of
them but i think a lot of them will be
so i think we're in a good spot to
just take the best available especially
after the free agency that we had we
signed a lot of really good players
got a lot of help on defense signed
riley reef at tackle he's going to help
us a lot um so we're in a really good
spot and you know i trust the
organization to do what they do and do
their jobs and pick the best player
hey there's a chance it's going to be
four for four quarterbacks before the
bengals pick at number five they could
have the de facto as far as they're
concerned number one overall pick two
years in a row because they weren't
going to take a quarterback with one of
the first four picks this plays out
perfectly for them especially if the
atlanta falcons go trey lance to follow
trevor lawrence zach wilson and mack
jones assuming that's what the 49ers do
so this is great for the bengals but at
some point you got to make a choice and
sharing i continue to believe they're
better off with penny sewell it's the
safer choice it's the way the bengals
have always seemed to be they're going
to be safe they're going to be smart and
they need someone to protect joe burr
and they had that bad experience with
john ross ninth overall pick four years
ago at receiver the last guy taken
before patrick mahomes i think that
makes them more inclined to go with a
safer pick and
even though there have been busts at
offensive tackle most notably tony
manderich but plenty of others as well
the bust rate traditionally has been
lower for high-end tackles in the top
ten
and if i'm jamar chase i pick up the
phone immediately when i see that quote
and i'm calling joe burrow and go come
on man what are you doing because you
remember last year
this really stuck out to me mike last
year kyler murray pitched hard for cd
lamb i want seedy lamb let's go get
seedy lamb he's my guy seedy lamb cd
lamb silly lamb what is the harm in
pushing for your guy it tells me that
that he wants pine sol that's what it
tells me he wants that left tackle they
didn't protect him very well last year
he got the knee injury he wants that
addition to the offensive line that's
going to give him more time he likes his
receiving core that's what that told me
mike that he would prefer let's go with
the big offensive tackle who's going to
be really good for a really long time
rather than as you said a receiver there
are plenty of receivers in this draft if
they need a receiver then go get a
receiver in the second round but but
their their receiver cord looks pretty
good even if they don't add to it
also a chance he's been paying very
close attention to some of the issues
that have popped up in other cities
where starting quarterbacks have wanted
to have greater involvement like a
russell wilson and there's been
arguments that maybe aaron rodgers
should be more involved in picking
personnel and maybe burrow is just
trying to create an early career
firewall where that's not going to be
the guy who i am at least not publicly
because no matter what he says publicly
he could be saying something else
privately and he's decided it's better
to just come off right as a guy who
knows his place
and and he can always explain it to
jamar chase later if and when the
bengals take uh penny sewell and i think
that's who they will
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports